die neuenhagener ausgangs regeln die
heute nämlich in ich schaue mal auf die
uhr ja knapp zehn minuten in bayern in
kraft treten
rausgehen ist noch erlaubt ausgehen es
aber nicht mehr erlaubt rausgehen
nämlich nur noch dann wenn man wichtige
einkäufe zu tätigen hat oder wenn man
zur arbeit gibt muss aber alle unnötigen
sozialen kontakte alles unnötige auf die
straße gehen das muss ab jetzt
unterbunden werden und die polizei in
münchen hat angekündigt notfalls auch
strafen zu verhängen hatte geldstrafen
bis zu 25.000 euro so heißt es heute von
der polizei in münchen wir sehen diesen
tweet dazu abgesetzt am abend das soll
keine drohung sein seien alle bayern
oder alle münchner aber doch die ganz
ganz dringende und ernst gemeinte
aufforderung sich an diese neuen harten
regeln in bayern eben zu halten
wir haben gerade noch mal bilder aus der
münchner innenstadt gesehen und genau da
gehen wir jetzt noch einmal hin live zu
meinem kollegen andreas bachner der am
marienplatz in münchen steht es ist
schlechtes wetter das haben wir schon
gesehen bei dir andreas trotzdem werde
jetzt vermutlich ein bisschen mehr los
als gerade schilder uns ein bisschen
bitte andreas wie sich die münchner auf
diese neuen ausgangs regeln einrichten
also hier werden am freitagabend
normalerweise menschen unterwegs die von
bar zu bar ziehen würden
die basis seit tagen geschlossen das ist
ohnehin nicht mehr der fall
aber es ist tatsächlich gespenstisch in
münchen in den letzten stunden haben
sich die straßen gelehrt es waren nur
noch ganz vereinzelt menschen unterwegs
eigentlich auch nur noch taxen die auch
leer waren trambahn die leer waren also
die menschen haben sich heute schon
darauf eingestellt was über waren heute
noch mal in der stadt unterwegs
viele waren draußen aber haben sich auch
auf die an die auflagen gehalten und um
sich nicht mehr in gruppen getroffen
heute waren sie sehr vernünftig die
menschen haben sich darauf eingestellt
aber es ist tatsächlich eine bedrückende
szenerie hier in der stadt wie man die
manche leichter erfolgs vor vier jahren
nach dem amoklauf am osz gesehen hat da
war es da war es drei vier tage lang so
dass die
leer war jetzt wird zumindest 14 tage
lang so sein
trotzdem gab's kuriose kuriose situation
etwa von einem baumarkt wo 2 300 leute
schlange standen die heute noch die
heute noch geöffnet hatten um sich
einzudecken
auch da hatte ein baumarktleiter zu mir
gesagt es waren zwei dreitausend heute
am tag da also auch da waren die
bedrückende stimmung die leute sind aber
grundsätzlich gelassen haben nicht
unbedingt angst vor der krankheit als
solches auch wenn die zahlen extrem
angestiegen sind hier in münchen allein
über nacht 202 neue infizierte
vor allem haben die leute eher angst vor
den wirtschaftlichen folgen und deswegen
ist es jetzt auch etwas bedrückt weil
jetzt jetzt kommt das tatsächlich auch
das öffentliche leben zum zum liegen in
nürnberg richtet man sich auch auf die
ausgangssperre ein die da in nach fünf
minuten dann in kraft tritt wie gehen
die nürnberger wie geht die stadt damit
um
halo ist es ja auch völlig ruhig in
nürnberg also kaum einer auf der straße
gespenstig fast wir sind im grund sieht
man das anders und bis nachts um zwei
geöffnet da ist immer also da geht die
post ab
auch auf der terrasse vorne aber ist
alles dunkel kein mensch auf der straße
ein polizei gesprochen gesagt es ist
relativ hohe geest nur ein paar
autofahrer die durch die altstadt düsen
natürlich verboten ist dann wird ab und
zu mal ein blaulicht eine serie zusagen
seien aber so ist es sehr ruhig also
ganz ruhig das ist schon mal glaubt also
wie nürnberger haben es verstanden was
jetzt zu tun ist
das ist schon eine historische stunde
die wir hier leben in 9 8 sekunden tritt
diese ausgangs beschränkung in ganz
bayern und eben auch in der
landeshauptstadt in kraft das bedeutet
rausgehen ist noch erlaubt in ganz
bestimmten fällen nämlich wenn man
einkaufen möchte dringende bedürfnis
besorgung machen möchte und wenn man
seine arbeit nachgehen muss aber
ansonsten sollte man sich zu hause
aufhalten so die anordnung der
bayerischen landesregierung um man
sollte eben soziale kontakte ab sofort
wirklich strikt meiden rausgehen noch
unter bestimmten bedingungen erlaubt
aber ausgehen eben nicht mehr ja es sind
tatsächlich nur noch polizeistreifen
unterwegs von ein paar minuten sind
tatsächlich noch ein paar menschen
runtergelaufen um noch schnell die s
bahn zu bekommen um wirkliches vor
mitternacht nach hause zu kommen also
das bild jetzt hier in kraft morgen am
samstag wäre es normalerweise so dass
wir haben platz hunderte von leute
stehen würden und sich das glockenspiel
dass viele touristen anlockt ansehen
würden film würden
dreimal am park ist das zu sehen das
kommt jetzt alles zum erliegen und die
menschen dürfen nur noch eigentlich zur
arbeit gehen oder kranke besuchen
arztpraxen welt versuchen natürlich
nicht außer aus triftigen grund aber in
arztpraxen gehen und die polizei wird
schicht kontrollieren das haben sie
angekündigt ist auch die meldung dass
ist ja hatte sprachen gehen wir bis zu
25.000 euro
das wird jetzt natürlich nicht nicht
mehr bei der ersten kontrolle der fall
sein werk wer tatsächlich einen
triftigen grund hat der hat nichts zu
befürchten aber die polizei hat
angekündigt bei wiederholungsfällen wird
es wird es harte strafen geben straßen
auf denen kaum noch autos fahren plätze
die normalerweise voll sind auf denen
keine menschen mehr zu sehen sind das
sind die bilder die uns seid ja einigen
tagen und erst recht seit diesen neuen
ausgangs beschränkungen in bayern
begleiten und vermutlich nun tage wochen
lang bundesweit begleiten werden lang
andreas